[Musica]
e muto gigante siamo tutti pazzi nuova
challenge prime come detto challenge noi
dobbiamo scegliere o meglio pescare cosa
dovremmo essere noi a sceglierli non
dobbiamo pescare il contenitore
sbagliato abbiamo coperto contenitori di
vari colori che dentro hanno vari
ingredienti alcuni tifosi e alcuni
fantastici ultima ora
e noi dovremo pescare ogni turno una di
queste strane passano solo perché dette
funzionanti la chiavetta corrisponde il
colore di ogni contenitore per il giallo
perché giallo non l'abbiamo trovata con
il giallo sarà costruzione specchiare in
ogni volta nel capiremo l'ordine di
queste fialette andremo a beccarli e i
contenitori che postiamo dobbiamo
portarlo nella nostra sotto la alla fine
vince
sempre chi allo stremo sibello è quello
che fa più sconti asl abbiamo imparato a
fare il trend tra la fine del video
io mi lascerò infondato pa dove potrete
votare se abitualità team senese o
vipava si ritrova più fronti prendete il
palatino causa del caldo quello che
volete tutti dio tutto schermo mettetevi
comodi e iniziamo subito diciamo carta
partecipato bella ciao carta forbice
cazzo di tenda e quindi o con creato
devo cambiare l'ordine delle elette
quindi e di figura e parla per fortuna
ho cambiato il rapporto d'alberto
gorizia che in realtà
stanca pieno sole quindi lo abbiamo
scelto per la mostra il nostro
contenitore rosa c'è anche perché lui
viaggia ce l'abbiamo e grosso non c'è
secondo voi che colore è questo più rosa
o più arancione
quindi il mio primo ingrediente sarà
questo giorno da colori trasparenza mi
sembra bello questo potere
ma c'è uno scambio scambio c'è un
bellissimo viola in treno con tanti
glitter denti ci sono anche i glitter
nesis tra l'altro ricche di uscire con
kalac si può essere visto che si sono
iscritte il viola
[Musica]
oddio perché sta sparendo il viola prima
l'ho detto più che ora sta ri colorando
la band at6 bendato perche mi raccomando
eh sbirciare aspetta
[Musica]
ok va sottovalutata dai pesca
tali reti tende però non vuol dire
niente perché non è detto che dal
contenitore a verde si stia colorante
verde purtroppo se non saremo già
peraltro era il contenitore è verde
sicuramente però cosa ci sarà di nuovo a
vedere bambola vai vediamo un po cosa
c'era dentro
ok promesso allora svitiamo il tappo
svitiamo alta sfidiamo ci sono le
palline così netta bellissimo ha detto
diventa antip la foto che tu che ti
preoccupavi del verde invece pare che
bello foto uscirai server come melita
janet blu ed è diventato verde
ovviamente
che bello non hanno chiaro se mi chiami
del blu di conte verde che quello già mi
piace indomina che entrambi cercano
all'inizio sì devo dire che finora molto
bello ma vediamo cosa succederà a creare
tra pompei si è mischiata 9 st mistero
del fatto
ok blu che cos'è non lo so ma un brutto
presentimento
anche se il colore del mio team e noi
abbiamo un
chissà che vincerà a parte che è
pesantissimo che presiede la mousse
palestra muffa poi draghi devono darmi
dire la maledizione non mi diano soldi
ma d'africa che di quello che c'è e che
devo aprire il tappo perfetto
fantastica la fertilità sfiga buca cos'è
quella cosa brutta
oddio guarda e book gigante verde
ovviamente ma è terribile che è buono e
granita magari sarebbe fantastico guarda
tronco di troll gigantesco c'è questo
perde non è normale proprio per debutto
nova la maturità stria e manutenzione
del verde guarda non ci posso credere
ogni video
ora come vivente mio bellissimo slam di
quella montescuro vediamo che colore
diventerà verde palude dai queste scilla
rete dove stanno i girini accelerare
stranissima ed è diventato che con un
ente condotte verde stagno verde palude
non è verde grigio tipo scritto temono
mia
vabbè magari essere un nuovo tipo di
slime che fa un sacco di suo
spero di salvarmi con i prossimi
contenitori si tocca si viola punto
ormai già capito chi vincerà quarta
spero che ti capiti aspetta vede un
mischiare ok fi base di un po più avanti
ok è pescato il viola che come viola
giocheranno dentro effettivamente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma che si giocheranno una torta però
questo è verde metallizzato carino
questo bene così carino con di vittoria
mosca 9 è finito il figlio ha dovuto
ammettere tutto guardate affido altro
contenitore adatto non scende
vediamo se vuoi far bene ora vediamo
abbiamo visto non c'è niente da vedere e
di raffa letta dentro troppo blu di un
blu bellissimo verde acqua per questa
parte a con un altro record e acqua
pastello vero sul battello questo bravo
sempre perdere anche questo che rimarrà
no c'è guarda che bellissimi sliven berg
e grigia a seguire questo mio verde è
bellissimo vediamo quello che capiterà
dopo tanti piange del verde è bellissimo
ma la converte pastello perde quasi
pistacchio detto il ristagno pastello
ok ora tutto il cairo estero l'ultima
fiscale perché quell'altro prenderei il
pd è fatto bene
io spero di pescare spero di cercare il
rosso quarta con uno dai robot che ha
spedito schede posso perché mi sembra
più bello che viene cosa voglio perché
tanto che caminanti fermata opposta non
c'è quindi grande il blu è ovviamente
attraverso vedo che c'è del verde 48 ci
sono tre due colori sotto c'è blu e
giallo sant e visto che l'ultimo anno e
scatta il rosso che consistenza strada è
aperta rosso speriamo che rapì e mister
hyde verde quindi alla fine tu il
pescato viola verde e il rosso e io blu
arancione e giallo sono i berliner e
allora ecco ora aggiungo l'ultimo
bottiglie la mia
canta il cocco vediamo se la salva anche
qua il verde a punti o successo esploso
mamma mia che qualcosa di strano però
non è più bello non è non è questo
bruttissimo ma allora almeno ci sono
pallini che stanno uscendo vedete ottimo
è super liquido tra l'altro adesso
vediamo ha presentato il ricco dentro
c'erano vari colori però tutti gli
spiati lo hanno reso verde ovviamente
per la mia maledizione che ora lo
mischio my super liquido oddio
spero che sfilano al club penso che io
sia una slime super gigi lee perché però
c'è anche la neve finta e tutte quelle
colpite tranne quindi non ed è di che
cosa uscirà da questa cosa sarà
veramente strano questo storheim e verde
ovviamente di un colore bellissimo per
questa specie è che sono molti versi
questi verdi il mio padre mi ha nominato
come evidente adesso allora io mi sa che
lo commetterlo così ma e blu
mondino chestrano diventa una palude che
la vediamo un po che coloro uscirà fuori
da già diventato un liquido o di cio che
tramite sta separando tutto dobbiamo
fare due climber b non è possibile
mantenere questa volta ha colpito tutto
il tempo erano marebbe rovinarlo è
rimasto that e consigli in verde rimane
sempre per sono i venerdì differenti
molto diversi quale verde vi piace di
più e meno aver infranto dati farlo
perché siamo islamico liquidino ma forze
forse ce la facciamo
ok allora andiamo ad attivarli vediamo
innanzitutto vediamo se ci riusciamo a
dare il voto ai ragazzi ecco il mio
slime allora vi spiego
pensavo che non ce l'avrei fatta in
realtà dopo già dicendo mai sto già
pensando questo sarebbe morto sarà
impossibile da attivare perché era lì
cui dissi ma come potete vedere dalla
consistenza sicli c'era troppa acqua e
pensavo che non sarei mai riuscita ad
altri valenza sia tuttora vedete come è
un po il liquido
invece poi ho continuato a un mischiato
rischiano mischiano sta tutta qua che
cosa ma se non riuscita la separa
incredibile riuscito una forza dei gip
lì però essendoci la neve finta a una
assistenza un po particolare diciamo
giachino zoe guardate un po splatter
hawking non è molto rumoroso proprio
perché più di clip è rimasto aperto e
completo purtroppo però una sorta di
verde scuro però si è molto particolare
come il flyer diciamo non è una
consistenza molto normale quindi che
voto gli date da una 10 de antoni pure
un nome
veniamo quello di evitarle il mio
scivola via
hai fatto un cenno portarlo cosa scrive
line up che bene ma sembrano
rispecchiare si sembra la superficie
lunare tutte le bollicine e stupendo
anche il mio abbastanza morbido
l'ultimo ingrediente reso molto molto
debito
per fortuna c'era la schiuma da barba
che l'ha fatto diventare un po più fra
forno
c'è pochi però siamo migliorati svizzera
per creare finalmente letto tutti i
commenti di mirano a tutti i consiglieri
si è imparato
si ringraziano voi incredibile posso
credere
i suoni bellissime super soffice bello
morbidoso frequento si allunga stupendo
non lenzuolo praticamente nord sia
bellissimo stupendo allora stati pure al
massimo dei voti
la disney ma perché davvero spettacolare
in spiaggia vediamo e ha vinto adesso è
diventato più celestino si sta perdendo
un colore celeste si amalgamo to me è
provveduto smorzi ops è un terzino è
forte ma che a messina e malengo monzino
giblin magazine online
già ma è un fermo nei
di qua no in vendita ma mi piace
veramente un serpente verde un tema
verde che si sta suicidando
mammamia sta cadendo a pezzi le
insegnano invece rimane super bellissimo
dell'elastico dopo ti faccio giocare
anche col mio bilancio poi a san basso
in cui potete votare che o interi note
ha vinto vitali pochi strappo o video
capito mi raccomando al 100 per cento da
dovuto alla vita scaglia cento per cento
vi lasciamo ora quattro gatti lines
criticare uno stratega nostri cia le
sfide di halloween
cliccate su quella che preferite
revisore